marie-sophie hervé amené avons vécu
l'enfer alors qu'il se trouvait en
hongrie au championnat du monde de la
fédération internationale de natation
se
fait draguer pixar
la nageuse de 22 ans a de bonnes raisons
de croire qu'elle a été drogué à son
insu lors d'une soirée en compagnie
d'autres athlètes où elles n'auraient
consommé quelques verres deux nageuses
de l'équipe française sont venus à sa
rescousse à l'extérieur du bar où elle
se trouvait je ne pourrais pas dire
quand elle est tombée inconsciente mais
a ainsi moment j'ai tombée inconsciente
puisons divers rapportés dans ma chambre
d'hôtel en mai
d'autres athlètes auraient possiblement
vécu le même traitement que marie sophie
harvey durant la même soirée
entre-temps natation canada revoit la
sécurité des athlètes y lance une
enquête
à son retour au québec marie sophie
harvey déplore le manque de ressources
et le chemin très ardue pour obtenir de
l'aide à 9h le sens j'ai trouvé ce
reportage laisser mes cordes et puis
malheureusement je sais des nouvelles de
jours plus tôt mais je dirais que oui il
ya quand même certaines ressources est
ce qu'elles sont toutes connues est ce
qu'elles sont méconnus total dans le
milieu on convient qu'il n'est pas
simple pour les victimes de s'y
retrouver on leur dit d'aller voir la
police d'aller aux hôpitaux mais ensuite
si elle tombe sur les bords vocale mais
reste quand même en gros tu roules à
l'éviction conclut laissée à elle même
dans tout ça c'est ce qui est vraiment
triste parce que ça prend un
accompagnement très sain dans le milieu
on convient qu'il n'est pas simple pour
les victimes de s'y retrouver le manque
de main d'oeuvre et la période des
vacances ils jouent pour beaucoup selon
cette intervenante qui espère que tous
les acteurs du milieu mettront leurs
efforts en commun pour contrer ce fléau
ici gabriel proulx radio canada montréal